meanwhile the u.s set another record for
coronavirus cases over the weekend
topping
20 million overall and the rollout of
the new vaccine
is not keeping up with the need for them
people waited in line for hours at this
site in texas to get shots and other
people
were camping out overnight in florida
after some say they were turned away
because of the limited supply health
care providers remain overwhelmed by the
pandemic
so far only 4.2 million americans have
been vaccinated according to the cdc
keep in mind that is far
short of the trump administration's
original goal of vaccinating
20 million americans by the end of
december the u.s surgeon general vice
admiral jerome adams joins us now he's a
member of the white house coronavirus
task force
dr adams good morning thank you so much
for being with us uh as good morning
good morning guys
as you heard tony just say uh the trump
administration
said that 20 million people would be
back would have been vaccinated by the
end of
of 2020. we are at about 4.2 million
people
why is this taking so long well let's be
clear here what we've consistently said
is that we would have 20 million doses
available
and operation warp speed has delivered
on that i want to level set with people
we're three weeks into
the largest vaccination program in
united states history
and any public health official you talk
to i ran a health department but
asked tony fauci we had a conversation
about this when you look at h1n1
which was under a different
administration we knew this was going to
take time
to increase and we're seeing it rapidly
increase in the 72 hours before the
previous report
you had 1.5 million vaccine doses
that were reported in three days so that
means 500 000 a day we
are ramping up and it's important for
the american people to understand that
because they have sacrificed
so much they need hope i want people to
understand that less than a year after
sequencing this virus we have 15 to 20
million doses
of vaccine available and we should be
we should we should be uh hopeful about
that while acknowledging that we've got
to do better and we're going to keep
doing better and i promise you
you'll see in the next two weeks these
numbers increase uh substantially the
development of the vaccine
is extraordinary dr adams but i mean you
look at israel which i know is a much
smaller country
but 10 of israel is already vaccinated
and 40 percent of people over the age of
60.
so i'm wondering the states are
suggesting it's a federal problem
the trump administration has suggested
it's a state problem where do you see it
lying
well the answer is yes and again i ran a
state health department
a lot of the authority lies at the state
level you need federal support
you need state participation and you
also have to take into account vaccine
hesitancy you had governor dewine saying
last week
that 60 of the nursing homes in his
state uh
nursing home workers wouldn't get a
vaccine so we've got to work on
all of these things and we really are
working on all of these things
together you've also got to understand
that some states are using all their
vaccine
other states haven't even used 25 of
their vaccine that's on the ground so
what we're doing in a concrete manner
is we're actually looking jurisdiction
by jurisdiction from a federal
perspective
and we're going to start moving those
doses around so that they can be
appropriately utilized
you also talked in your teaser about
other things we're looking at like
potentially having the dose we're going
to let the science lead the way
we're going to make sure we're getting
as much vaccine to as many people as
possible and getting it into arms
well so do you do you do you see a
potential solution
in delaying the second dose as some
people are suggesting
or even having the first dose or do you
think science eliminates that
as a possibility well i think again we
need to let science lead the way
uh tony fauci has said clearly that he
does not think it's appropriate for us
to eliminate the second dose or push it
back at this point
but we are looking again at having the
dose and again if we double the number
of doses
but there's still not uptake then it's
not going to make a difference so we've
got to deal with uptake and hesitancy in
the quarters where that's going to
matter
we've got to increase availability in
the places that's going to matter
and we're working on that you'll see
that happen today we've got a governor's
call today where we're going to talk to
the governors
and we've always said to them tell us
what you need and we will give it to you
and when you actually question governors
directly very few of them will tell you
that they aren't getting what they need
when they ask many of them call me and i
respond immediately i pick up my phone
24 hours a day
i know dr adams you've spoken out very
often about the
the hesitancy in the black community in
the minority community about taking the
vaccine
and now a survey shows that a third of
essential and health care workers
also have some hesit hesitancy about
taking the vaccine
so how how do you plan to address this
what do people need to know
again about this vaccine gail happy new
year and i'm so glad you asked that
question because
hidden within what you just said is the
fact that the healthcare workers least
likely to take the vaccine
are healthcare workers of color
healthcare workers who are harder hit
by this virus and so we're continuing to
acknowledge uh the the the concerns that
they have based on tuskegee based on
henrietta lacks based on real harms that
have happened in the past and harms that
are happening
right now in this country when you look
at indiana
at the black doctor who unfortunately
passed away
due to covet 19. these things are
happening now we acknowledge them
we have to answer people's questions
honestly and npr had a great story
about a cherokee woman who was hesitant
to get the vaccine
she asked her questions she got them
answered in a compassionate
and meaningful way and she decided to
get the vaccine and then we're engaging
with trusted influencers i talked to one
of your friends this weekend
miss oprah winfrey about what we could
do and
she mentioned that tyler perry is going
to get going to help promote vaccine
confidence that she wanted to work with
me to help promote vaccine confidence
we want people who have influence in
communities to use that influence
and get fat people the facts that they
need so they can make an informed choice
oh okay you talked to oprah okay i
couldn't reach her on the phone
she was busy but before you go i know
your wife has been hospitalized for her
for her issues with cancer and it
prevented you from seeing her
because of covid restrictions how's she
doing and
what's your what's your message to
people who have to take these
precautions
because you couldn't see your own wife
well she's stable now she's back at home
getting treated as an outpatient so
we're very grateful for that
but the message i want people to take
home is that even if you aren't
worried about getting coveted and a lot
of people just aren't worried about
getting coveted because
you're 50 times more likely to know
someone who's recovered from coven
than you are to know someone who's died
from covert those are just the stats
but people need to be concerned
regardless because cases
turn into hospitalizations and it means
that i can't visit my wife in the
hospital it means that if you have
someone getting a car wreck who you love
they may not have a
bed in the hospital for you this has
implications beyond
covid so please wear a mask wash your
hands watch your distance
get your vaccine when you can surgeon
general jerome adams dr jerome adams
thank you so much again for being with
us this morning
thank you happy new year happy new year